moi je suis charlie un hommage et un
solidarité avec ceux qui sont tombés
sous les balles de la barbarie de 7
janvier de que je rassure je suis
charlie pour ça est-ce que je suis
charlie hebdo est ce que la manière d'un
charlie hebdo traite l'actualité par la
caricature et le côté ça tire
franchement non mais je tourne la tête
je l'achète pas déçus qui ont mis
l'acheter comme eric de l'eau et qui ça
fait rire l'achète et moi je suis pour
que nous puissions les uns les autres au
nom de notre libre arbitre de nos
convictions nous notre sensibilité de
que pouvoir en dehors de ce drame qu'il
a nous a unis et j'ai du mal à penser
que en dehors de ce que je dirai que
d'un saut dames on puisse pas être
charlie après j'accepte qu'on ne le soit
pas au delà est-ce que ça près très
franchement mais quand je dis je suis
charlie heins solidarité à ceux qui sont
tombés sur la barbarie et j'ai envie de
vous dire je suis ouigours je suis sarah
halimi oui je suis palestinien cas de
gaza bombardée j'ai envie de dire que ma
sensibilité à moi c'est que je me sente
partie prenante de ceux qui sont sous sa
place à la barre marie aline uni et
darty fait là je suis capable de me
raconter mais là et donc je suis naturel
car il peut tout mélanger dans vos
exemples du tout ce qu'il veut c'est ce
qu'on est
oui mais si c'est parce que on en parle
à porte certains le pensent que c'est
l'arrêt je vous dis si on regarde sa
sensibilité personnelle
moi ma sensibilité c'est être là sous
les regards de ceux qui sont en
souffrance des rochers du sont en
souffrance je suis jésus
nous on le reconnaît comme un prophète
bernard l'a pas non moi être être
charlie s'était pas nécessairement que
pour les jeunes de choc de charlie hebdo
c'était pour tous ceux qui avaient été
attaqués pour moitié ça c'était il y
avait de la compassion pour tous ces
jeunes qui avaient été assassinés pas
nécessairement que les gens de charlie
hebdo
je suis désolé et quand il y avait des
millions de personnes dans la rue ces
millions de personnes il lisait pas
charlie hebdo nas et on s'est tous
sentis attaqués pays ont ces niveaux là
il fait solidaire donc c'est peut-être
beaucoup de compassion
ce n'était pas nécessairement échalier
d'eau après moi je fais partie comme
karim de ceux qui le lisent pas chez les
ados et ça me fait pas rire
je comprends que ça ne passerait 38% des
français aujourd'hui qui se disent ne
pas être charlize quand même énorme
ça va c'est quand même c'est quand même
fou parce que la compassion elle part
avec le temps mais là mais on est obligé
en fait on a l'impression qu'on est
sommes dans une forme de dictature de la
pensée
si tu n'es pas charlie effectivement il
ya quelque chose de louche chez toi
c'est que tu es solidaire et les
terroristes
non non je suis désolé on peux tu peux
ne pas être insensibilité avec charlie
aussi manichéen que sannois ces normes
si les dents quand tu penses que non
remontants dès lors en plus de ceux qui
se déclarent donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup plus alors martin mais je pense
que il ya la notion de je suis charlys
d'élite avec le temps c'est à dire qu'à
l'instant t lorsqu'il ya tous ces
millions de personnes dans la rue le 11
janvier
tout le monde sait pourquoi on est
charlie aujourd'hui on ne sait plus
pourquoi on devrait aller pourquoi parce
que chacun ici a une définition de je
suis jamais est ce que vous pensez aux
différentes vous pose la question du
juste christine est ce que vous pensez
pas que je pose voilà je voudrais dire
ce soir je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable
est ce que vous pensez pas et c'est ce
qui se dit aussi sur twitter que les
provocations de charlie hebdo d une de
charlie hebdo ont provoqué aussi chez
certains
un refus qui se dit ça on n'a plus envie
d'être charlie parce que on accroche
plus avec bien sûr très inspiré mais
cyril à la jambe a été longtemps ils ne
seront plus que c'était charité ça ne
les avait pas beaucoup je ne savais pas
où j'étais là par compassion peu après
qu'elle se soit rendu compte
effectivement d et c est ça je suis
désolé mais moi ça me plaît pas je sais
ça c'est vrai oui
christine non mais sur le coup le jeu
suit chaque année il ya des gens qui on
est comme a dit
eric naulleau qui ont été tués parce
pour la liberté des liens sociaux
c'est inconcevable c'est intolérable ce
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas possible
qu'on puisse tuer quelqu'un pour la
liberté d'expression
c'est dans la constitution c'est dans
les textes la première - dans la
constellation aux états unis en france
et doit on ne peut pas semer
non mais quel peuple c'est quand tu es
donc je me dis j'ai mérité désigné voir
l'état islamique nommément sous-entendu
que leur mort est différente de celle
des autres machines à mort reste un mort
une ville et c'est une haute gironde
l'a62 sacraliser la mort de charlie
hebdo au drift détriment des autres
attentats et je pense que c'est ça dans
la tête des gens qui se dit mais charlie
hebdo leur mort s'est résolument le seul
à faire cette hiérarchie on ne compte
pas les morts mais penser au droit quand
quelqu'un est assassiné à cause de ce
qu'ils n'aient il ya des circonstances
aggravantes
c'est une autre qualification dans le
droit c'est ce qui soudera de bataille
car est assassiné parce qu'il en
situation de vulnérabilité
on juge plus dur - sont accusés
donc c'est pas une question de valeurs
ce sont des êtres humains ce sont des
pères ce sont des maris qui sont morts
par contre ce sont des journalistes qui
ont été visés parce qu'on dit souvent la
liberté d'expression ce sont des
journalistes ce sont vos collègues et ça
n'arrivait pas dans une démocratie que
cela n'arrivait pas en oeuvre dans les
dictatures qu'on assassine est des
jaunes c'est pour ça que ça emule monde
et je trouve formidable que vous ayez
passé c'est une y compris celles vous
vous moquant parce que quand caroline
fourest a voulu montrer le charlie hebdo
la journaliste anglaise non non nous
avions demandé deux pas du tout faire
vous allez offenser les pauvres gens est
ce que maintenant je vais m'arrêter à ce
qui offense les jambes un nom parce que
à ce compte là qui va décider
on va faire appel à des scènes city
voiture ce qui vous dire maintenant vous
parlez pas des handicaps vous parlez pas
de la mort pour page peiné notre chère
madame de fontenay
vous ne parlez pas de ça vous ne parlez
pas de ça ça c'est pas la technique de
charlie hebdo au fur et à mesure qu'ils
vont blesser la sensibilité des gens
avec les musulmans
les catholiques les juifs
ils ont fait passer cette hausse est la
caricature du piano c'est pas
l'agriculture de tuer c'est pour ça que
les gens en général il ya 38 pour cent
pour sang qu'est ce qui fait que ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses maintenant
charlie au début c'était ce que j'ai dit
mais maintenant c est ce que tu es
français
est-ce que tu défends la lie de ça est
ce que tu es mais est-ce que voilà c'est
au début septembre mais rose à la raison
au questionnement que je suis charlie
sheen à autre chose derrière comptes
rendus des cent des gens disent que je
ne suis plus charlie ça vient toucher
des séries régionales